qui sont ces enfants au coeur de l'art
il que représente pour eux cette terre
donné en héritage comment prend-il soin
de ce jardin multiples facettes
pourrait-il vivre sans lui 7 il les a vu
grandir ainsi tout comme ils sont les
témoins de son histoire la réunion porte
en elle leur parole une parole qui n'est
mûri se développe sur les sentiers c'est
au coeur de ces sentiers de ces chemins
étroits que chacun d'entre eux
parviendra à se libérer et à livrer une
part de lui l'en sol ou sur ces sentiers
société rites et ses sentiers foulée ses
sentiers m cissé s'est senti à protéger
[Musique]
il est une île fier aux rives de basalte
au sommet enivré d'azur et de soleil que
neil dans le coeur enthousiasmé s'exalte
soul ardente fournaise et les grands
soirs vers mais
[Musique]
moi je fais déjà partie marché à
plusieurs endroits différents mais mon
endroit préféré ça reste quand même un
parc à la ravine blanche à la plaine des
cafres j'aime bien les là bas parce que
ça me libère l'esprit ce que j'ai adoré
là bas c'est que mon ami elle m'a
expliqué toutes sortes de plantes
qu'elle avait eu avec sa mère je voyais
fait c'était le grand baie nord 6 heures
mais par contre les la largue d'avaler
quand même la peine puisque c'était
magnifique on a passé un très bon moment
alors ils n'y ont déjà on a deux très
beaux cyr nos trois magnifiques cirques
mafate cilaos salazie c'est pas donné à
tout le monde d'avoir ses décibels
randonnée qu'on peut qu'on peut
facilement pratique et
on se sent tout petit comparé à ses
immenses montagnes et moi ce que j'aime
pas du tout dans les antilles il ya
plein de déchets donc voix - arnaud
coyot alors que la voiture centrale
immense
te rappelles-tu saisi manche tout
languissant celle hammam et où leur
déjeuner sous les branches ombreuses du
méco coullier
europe en famille chez moi se passe très
bien gm en faire et mon tonton qui
prépare les hippies ce qu'on va faire un
massage à calvi avec voix citrouille
four se sont libérés sur le lieu de
binic
chez moi les repas de famille se passe
bien on rigole on joue avec mes cousins
cousines on se raconte des choses qui se
passent le plus en ce moment au mordant
dévale dans des feuilles bananes des
roues gaye décarie deux pas de la
réunion les repas sont plutôt des plats
traditionnels de madagascar comme les
rom hasard ou lis ça ben on peut aussi
les mélanger les repas réunionnais
annonce tous ensemble tout le monde aide
confie massalé cac avec toi massa les
citrouilles ont fait aussi décidé après
manger en bois tous du téat pour manger
gâteau et à la fin on danse tous
ensemble
[Musique]
l' esclavage en un mot pour moi ça
serait
malheur
on homo s'est cru torture en un mot les
esclavages pour moi ça se crée la
souffrance maltraitance
pour moi l'esclavagé en un mot c'est la
privation de liberté ce serait une
humanité
c'est l'inégalité
c'est de l'injustice pour moi les
esclavages c'est l'intolérance l'esclave
vache c'est inqualifiable
quand je pense à l' esclavage le mot qui
me vient en tête c'est l'abolition
au 10 mois donc enfants de la race
créole d'où vient que pour nos bords
tout cas récents amour d'où vient que
faible encore ta première parole dans
l'avenir douteux semble arrêter le jour
d'un départ sans retour
[Musique]
non je me vois pas quitter cette cible
parce que c'est ma ville à moi j'ai fait
mes premiers pas et j'ai dit mes
premiers mots sur 7 6
ici à ma famille mes amis et un jour
j'aimerais faire grandir mes enfants à
l'île de la réunion
pour pouvoir les faire connaître leurs
grands parents et arrière grands parents
s'étaient vus pour moi c'est tout pour
moi c'est mon coeur c'est là où j'ai
grandi sinon je suis né je suis
quitterai jamais attiré j'y réfléchis
encore je ne sais quoi je pense qu'un le
juge pourra quitter l'île de la réunion
même si c'est lille où j'ai grandi il ya
tellement d'endroits est tellement de
gens à rencontrer dans ce monde mais je
reviendrai toujours à neil parce que je
suis trop attaché
qui sont ces enfants au coeur de leur
île que représente pour eux cette terre
donné en héritage comment prend-il soin
de ce jardin aux multiples facettes
pourrait séduire sans lui 7 il les a vu
grandir
ainsi tout comme et sont les témoins de
son histoire la réunion porte en elle
leur parole
c'est au coeur de ces sentiers de ces
chemins étroits que chacun d'entre eux
est parvenu à se libérer et à livrer une
part de lui ses confessions ont permis à
ces adolescents de faire entendre leur
voix comme s'il nous avait été donné
d'entendre leurs pensées leurs secrets
leurs moi tout simplement
[Musique]